[Musique]
ce sont vraiment des travaux qui sont
assez uniques discussions transnationaux
à des scènes d'action et on est content
d'avoir pu les rassembler aujourd'hui à
l'occasion la présidence française de
l'union
en
europe la route
tracée pelling which does he is au
moins
les six nominés type
soyouz lancée
en faisant connaître des artistes aux
mineurs des
nouvelles idées reçues culte puissent
finir le plus grand sans restriction aux
frontières montrer le revenu citoyen
qui en france
le travail que vous êtes en train de
regarder c'est un travail sous les
académies européenne j'ai parcouru
l'europe entière c'est un travail qui
intègre vente academy en ce pays ça a
duré cinq ans et le vrai boute de
travail c'est de raconter un petit peu
la lame européenne à travers les
nouvelles générations d'officiers qui
font des ponts entre la tradition les
futurs et ils vont incarner la nouvelle
génération d'européens
j'ai parcouru 20 mille kilomètres des
frontières préalpes et en europe et j'ai
fait ça sur une période de deux ans et
donc ces images sont une petite
sélection des 5 franck images du projet
engrangé pris en photo une utopie qui
est devenu réalité il ya 50 ans
imaginer une europe où on pouvait
circuler librement et technique aux pays
et jeudi c'est devenu réalité et moi
j'ai la chance de la première photo il
peut y avoir ici à l'édition
project est multiforme
que
si
dur et
un regard
tout l'été pour que des points de suture
elle juge essentielle
de
cette institution je présente les
projets lance t
on à d'autres mutations du paysage
d'impôt début l'habituel son hub finance
et d'économie prises dans la mer des
eaux côtières des différents parkings le
ensemble des images de son gérant où les
coptes continue
paysages uniques au paysage continuer
sans fil
[Musique]
je me réjouis de voir
en mouvement une
au début des années 90 j'ai découvert
les premiers pays de l'est qui s'ouvrait
quai de voyager beaucoup
puis dans les années 2000 j'ai continué
à suivre ces pays qui rentrait dans
l'union puis les tailler 2010 j'ai
continué ce travail sur toute l'union
européenne
pour voir un peu plus communs aussi
l'union
s'uniformise est comment les décors sont
uniformisés dans les centre-villes par
exemple
le sait la
sécu
généralement partage ça ait commencé
avec la terre vue du ciel
et nous voyons fait le ciel de l'europe
outre leurs organes